thug lat North Korea we haven't heard
much about North Korea since the big
summit in Singapore and it turns out
that nobody at the US State Department
has heard much from North Korea
since that summit Donald Trump is now
claiming that North Korean
denuclearization has begun and that
caused actual experts and officials to
say wait what is he talking about
and we knew that it would happen we knew
that when Donald Trump said he won at
that Singapore North Korea summit that
he would claim victory indefinitely no
matter what happened and that his
followers would fall for it and he's
doing it Donald Trump said at a recent
cabinet meeting quote total
denuclearization has already started
they stopped sending they've stopped the
sending of missiles including ballistic
missiles they're destroying their engine
site they're blowing it up
they've already blown up one of their
big test sites in fact it's actually
four of their big test sites and the big
thing is it will be a total
denuclearization which has already
started taking place sounds like big
winning right except that actual
officials who know what's going on so
there's no evidence whatsoever that any
denuclearization has started since the
summit nobody has any idea what Donald
Trump is referring to which nuclear test
sites what missiles what dismantling is
Trump talking about nobody knows because
it appears that Trump is making this up
out of thin air and even more we could
say hilariously or we could say
tragically the State Department now says
there has not even been contact with
North Korean officials since the summit
summit zero contact Secretary of Defense
Jim mattis was asked here's what Trump
said has North Korea done anything
towards denuclearization yet Jim mattis
said quote no I'm not aware of that the
Pentagon was asked to comment they
simply said no comment lies lies lies
but they work and there's this new breed
of political incompetent the trumpets
the trumpets Trump's winning story from
the summit they believe Trump's story
now that denuclearization is just
happening so cool
in the real world none of this stuff
exists but the trumpets it and then it
circles back to be doubly useful for
Trump because then a media outlet like
Reuters for example will simply report
the facts which is Trump says that
denuclearization is well on its way
officials say they don't know what the
hell Trump is talking about the trumpets
will then call that fake news even
though it's just the most fundamental
reporting of the facts on the ground I
understand that the Trump supporter will
believe Trump at all costs and they'll
write off negative stories about him as
fake news but how do they justify not
taking John Kelly's word or the
Pentagon's word after all these people
work for Trump right it's cognitive
dissonance I don't know I don't know but
it's it's a closed circle of reasoning
that you can't break into that's the
thing Trump said it and so it must be
true and Jim mattis didn't but Trump's
edit and reuters reported it but that's
fake news and they just decide that this
is just not what what that they will not
be influenced by anything other than
word from Donald Trump himself we've
talked about the difference between
politician lies and Trump lie yeah quite
a bit
usually politicians will all get on the
same page then their staffs they'll all
know what the narrative is yeah and
they'll push that forward Trump just
views this it's right off the top of his
head if there's any greater sign as to
the lack of hope that maybe we should
have that the trumpet will ever turn it
around is that they are not punishing
him I get not punishing your elected
officials for politician lies like the
dead is down well if measured this way
and the measure this way it's up these
are just straight-up verifiable lies and
they're still not punishing Trump for it
in any way that's actually the biggest
indictment on the Trump is the bigger
picture